heat of Maharana village is very hot. This fight is
not just a fight of the farmers, it is a fight of the common citizens
because the
sacrifice of these laws by the women who work will have to be borne by the
common Indians too, even today, not only in the elections but
also in the elections.  If it
can sell the hearts of the audience too, then they will go back to the black law.
This is not the fight of the farmers. This is not the fight of the farmers. Bring it once in a while, let it be the
youth that
Ajay, till he does not agree, the movement will
continue. The country is stuck in the fight for freedom.
[Music]
When is the loot movement, the latest news in Gurgaon was that
three and a half laws were to be withdrawn and
we are making guarantee law on SP. We had
started the farmer's movement with these things,
but you assumed that it was about
providing employment to the unemployed.  This demand has become to
save the bread of the poor. This demand has become to the
constitution of the country. This demand has become to save the fragrance of the country.
Oh
Ajay.